und ein ziel der russischen offensive
ist offenbar eben auch die 300.000
einwohner stadt terni hilft die im
norden der ukraine an der grenze zu
belarus liegt hier befindet sich nämlich
das sogenannte operative armeekommando
nord der ukrainischen streitkräfte ein
video soll hier nun den abschuss eines
russischen kampfjets seien
abschuss über der ukraine
dieses video veröffentlichen die
ukrainischen behörden am samstag
es soll einen russischen kampfjet zeigen
der in der nähe von cerny sie zu boden
geht
weitere aufnahmen sollen die
löscharbeiten nach dem absturz zeigen
weiter werden wohnhäuser beschossen wie
hier in bila zerkwa in der nähe von kiew
ein video der polizei zeigt das ausmaß
der zerstörung am
samstagmorgen soll es eigentlich eine
waffenruhe in mario pohl geben fünf
stunden zeit für die bewohner die stadt
zu verlassen doch schon kurz nach der
verkündung wieder schüsse die menschen
müssen zurück in die schutzräume am
samstagnachmittag setzt das russische
militär nach eigenen angaben die
angriffe auf mario pohl fort
laut dem menschenrechtsbüro der
vereinten nationen gibt es bisher
aufgrund der kämpfe in der ukraine
mindestens
351 bestätigte todesfälle unter
zivilisten
die tatsächlichen zahlen seien
wahrscheinlich viel höher
die meisten opfer wurden demnach bei
explosionen von granaten und raketen
oder bei luftangriffen getötet
tausende flüchtlinge die es aus der
ukraine heraus geschafft haben kommen
unterdessen in berlin an wann sie wieder
zurück in ihrer heimat können ist
ungewiss denn putins angriff geht
gnadenlos weiter
das wollen wir natürlich besprechen und
einschätzen bei mir im studio ist
bild-reporter björn stritzel also bieren
wir haben eben gesehen kampfjets über
wohngebieten im tiefflug sozusagen wie
schätzt du das ganze ein also dass sie
im tiefflug fliegen das hat den grund
dass eben putins armee immer noch nicht
die lufthoheit hat das heißt dass sie
versuchen da dem dem völlig nah da
sozusagen zu entgehen dass sie über
wohngebieten sind entspricht dieser
strategie die die russischen
streitkräfte zunehmend an zunehmend
einsetzen die wir auch in syrien gesehen
haben auch in tschetschenien gesehen
haben wohngebiete die sie selber nicht
erobern können unbewohnbar zu machen
also tatsächlich
so schwer zu bombardieren dass dort
niemand mehr leben kann das ist ja
gerade gesehen haben 134 also in bombay
der russischen russischen luftwaffe der
dann abgeschossen wurde wir haben es
ganz am anfang ich weiß wie man sehen
kann der wird noch tolle körper ab wird
aber dennoch abgeschlossen was darauf
hindeutet dass die waffe mit der er
abgeschossen wurde ein neueres modell
ist für alle die sich nicht so auskennt
teusch körper das soll ablenken so zu
sagen und die raketen dann in anhausen
ein selbstverteidigungssystem sozusagen
der eines eines luftfahrzeugs dass zum
beispiel
körperabwehr auf den stark sind sehr
starkes signal aussenden um dann
sozusagen ankommen rakete damit
abzulenken vom eigentlichen ziel dieser
diese luftabwehr waffe die die luft
rakete die in jet dennoch getroffen hat
ist mutmaßlich
wahrscheinlich eine neuere stinger
raketen die zuvor 34 jahren umfassende
modernisierung erfahren haben und dann
auch sozusagen unterscheiden können
zwischen solchen tausch körpern und dem
eigentlichen ziel interessant ist aber
dennoch dass sozusagen in den sozialen
medien und auch in der in den bildern
die die ukrainische streitkräfte selber
veröffentlichen gar nicht gerade von den
fingern isst sondern wären dann immer
ältere modelle russische modelle die
ukrainische armee auch hat also zum
beispiel diese klar bzw eine polnische
version davon gezeigt das kann das muss
nicht unbedingt heißen dass tatsächlich
eine solche waffe zum einsatz gekommen
ist sondern dass man sich vielleicht
auch darauf verständigt hat das ist
nicht unbedingt die finger zeigen möchte
beim abschluss eines russischen
flugzeugs damit sozusagen auch gewisse
dinge noch geheim bleiben was könnte der
hintergrund sein also zum einen
vielleicht dass das sozusagen genau
tatsächlich geheim bleibt wo die
eingesetzt werden wenn die eingesetzt
werden wie sie eingesetzt werden zum
anderen vielleicht war aber auch eine
der bitten sozusagen vielleicht der
deutschen regierung dass man gesagt hat
wir möchten nicht unbedingt das ist
jetzt groß in auf videos veröffentlicht
wird wie die deutsche waffen russische
flugzeuge abschießen wir wollen
gemeinsam noch mal auf ein weiteres
video schauen was uns gestern erreicht
hat da da soll ein russischer helikopter
von einer ukrainischen luftabwehr rakete
getroffen worden seien wir sehen es
jetzt hier genau am ende geht dann
dieser helikopter in einem feuerball auf
diese aufnahmen die kursieren bei social
media auch essien hatte darüber
berichtet
kannst du das ein bisschen einordnen für
uns also ist auch ein russischer
kampfhubschraubern ii 35 glaube ich und
der wird ja wird er quasi auch
sehr effektiv bekämpft hat natürlich
auch keine chance dort im tiefflug aber
du hast die bilder durchaus für echt
also die sind meiner festen überzeugung
nach vielleicht also da gibt es auch
groß montierende bilder von von teilen
von ja also auch was auch nicht nur
diese einzelne aufnahme anhand derer man
das dann verifizieren kann genau also
ist durchaus echt und auch das belegt
eben noch mal dass die dass die
russische armee weit davon entfernt ist
da die lufthoheit zu haben das ist und
es zeigt eben auch die effektivität
solcher solcher schulter gestützte
luftabwehrwaffen
haben uns noch weitere bilder erreicht
unter anderem von einem
liegengebliebenen russischen konvoi da
sehen wir dann ukrainische soldaten die
darum herum laufen und sich das ganze
anschauen
erklär uns mal was genau da passiert
sein könnte was wir da genau auch sehen
was das alles dafür material ist wasser
am boden
liegen geblieben hast du schon gesagt
genau also man könnte vermuten dass er
vielleicht im schnee aber
es ist zumindest wenn man sich die die
in den schaden an den fahrzeugen
angeschaut wahrscheinlich kein luft
schlag gewesen ist eigentlich nur dass
das führungsfahrzeug was man glaube ich
irgendwann vielleicht auch noch mal
video oder am anfang sieht was
tatsächlich schwer getroffen wurde
wahrscheinlich von auch von
panzerabwehrwaffe und ansonsten scheint
mir eher zu sein das ist das ist ist
dieser konflikt dass leute aus diesem
konvoi geflohen sind beziehungsweise
unter ja und in einen hinterhalt geraten
sind interessant ist dann noch die die
außenseiter gesehen haben ich weiß nicht
wann es zu sehen konnten war kurz zu
sehen
so ein schild ihnen das was was
polizisten einsetzen ja so ein letztes
lande sind genau er das das war ein
konvoi sozusagen der rus quartier also
der der russischen nationalgarde die dem
innenministerium eigentlich unterstellt
sind und die eigentlich dafür da sind ja
nicht im kampf gegen bewaffnete an mir
zu führen sondern so aufstände
kreiskasse weiter in ein anderer kampf
sondern sozusagen tatsächlich ja
demonstrationen nieder zu prügeln solche
sachen an diesem jahr mitunter haben
auch grenzschutz und so weiter aber das
ist eben kein kein converteam man also
keine einhalten die man einsetzen im
kampf gegen gegen eine feindliche armee
und das zeigt auch so ein bisschen die
die geringe flexibilität der russischen
streitkräfte die im zehnten elften tag
des krieges immer noch solche einheiten
reinstecken am anfang haben sie die auch
schon nach eingeschickt solche leicht
bewaffneten einheiten die eigentlich nur
dafür da sind eine bevölkerung zu
kontrollieren wurden dann komplett
aufgerieben und zehn tage später sind
sie nicht in der lage das sozusagen zu
tauschen sondern schicken da immer noch
solche einheiten rein und werden dann
halt von ukrainischen hinterhalt geraten
demokratische hinterhalte und werden
dann schwer auf geräten dürfte nicht im
interesse von wladimir putin sein wie
dieser teil seiner kriegsführung läuft
dankeschön für deine ganz aktuelle
einschätzung dazu